Have you considered giving a workshop on presentations, Mark?
What are you talking about, Bob?
You must be kidding.
No, bear with me for a minute.
I thought you gave a very dynamic presentation.
Really?
I sensed a bit of hostility during the questions at the end.
Not at all.
I just wanted you to be specific about the value you see in...
Of course I never did any formal analysis of the benefits of informal feedback.
Don't interrupt.
I was trying to tell you the organization, interaction, and professionalism of your presentation were impressive.
Maybe you could contribute some tips to help others here give better presentations.